Speaker 1: So public health officials were
starting to worry about this about six weeks
ago, and we worried we were likely about a
month away around mid-March and it's apparently
happening.
We are now seeing a slowdown in vaccinations,
not because of the temporary pause on the
Johnson and Johnson vaccine expected to resume
very soon, not because of the lack of vaccine
supply, not because of a lack of appointments
or a lack of vaccinators, as Joe Biden likes
to say.
But because supply is starting to exceed demand
for the vaccine in some of the more anti vaccine
strongholds, by which I mean mostly in twenty,
twenty one Republican areas where 43 percent
of the country's Republicans said at last
week's polling date they do not plan, nor
are they interested in getting the coronavirus
vaccine all over the country.
We are hearing about vaccine vaccination centers
with wide open appointments, even simply walk
in.
People were telling me in Mississippi it was
just come and walk in.
In Massachusetts, it was just simply come
and show up with no appointment.
In California, in some cases, vaccines going
unused, appointments going unfilled.
There are currently two hundred and seventy
seven million vaccines that have been distributed,
but only two hundred and fifteen million vaccines
that have been administered, meaning that
states are now sitting on 62 million doses
with more coming in on a regular basis.
Now, some of those 62 million are reserved
second doses for states that are still going
about it in that way.
But this is not a great sign.
Overall, we right now, as of yesterday, have
about 26 percent of the population fully vaccinated
and 40 percent has received at least one dose.
But the number of doses given has declined
to just about three million doses per day.
We had multiple days in the last week with
under two million doses per day given, which
is a reversal of the direction that things
were going.
We can crush this thing.
We actually have the tools, the resources
and the vaccine supply to crush this thing
if we keep vaccinating quickly, more quickly.
But instead, vaccination is slowing down.
It may be temporary.
We know that about 20 percent of the country
overall doesn't want a vaccine.
Overwhelmingly, that group is Republicans.
As I mentioned, 43 percent of Republicans
do not want the vaccine.
That's going to hurt our ability to fight
this.
And the very people who from the beginning
have said they want this over or at least
they want to act like it's over.
Well, we have a way to make it be over.
And it's called getting vaccinated.
But 43 percent of them don't want the vaccine.
That's going to hurt our ability to fight
this.
Now, one great thing that Joe Biden announced
yesterday is a tax credit for employers to
offer paid leave to workers to go and get
vaccinated.
We're going to talk about this more on the
bonus show.
Joe Biden tweeting, quote, I believe everyone
who wants the vaccine should be able to get
one.
Today, I announced the tax credit made possible
by the American rescue plan to help employers
offer paid leave to workers getting vaccinated.
You can learn more at IRS dot gov covid.
As things continue to open and the odds of
needing a vaccine to go certain places increases
that will probably encourage more people to
get vaccinated.
But understand that at this point it's not,
oh, how could we may be ended?
When could the end be in sight?
We could very quickly get to the pandemic
end game and of course in the fall we already
know there will likely be boosters for tailored
to the variants.
But as far as what we can do now to have a
very normal Fourth of July, just two and a
half months from now, to have a relatively
OK Memorial Day just five weeks from now,
if we keep vaccinating more quickly, we can
do it again.
Look at what's happening in Israel, where
56 percent of the country is fully vaccinated.
It's not 70 percent.
It's not 80 percent, with 56 percent fully
vaccinated in Israel.
Cases are so low that it almost looks like
zero on the chart that we are looking at,
it's actually about 140 cases per day.
The this is just the perfect example.
Israel and New Jersey have the same size and
the same population.
You look up geographic area for Israel and
New Jersey, it's almost the same.
You look at population, it's almost the same.
New Jersey has 4000 cases a day.
Israel has 140 just stunning.
And its vaccines deaths also, by the way,
approaching zero in Israel, about six per
day right now.
For comparison, New Jersey is averaging about
40 deaths a day.
Seven times the deaths in New Jersey than
in Israel.
Same population, same geographical size, and
it is vaccines.
If we can just stay at three million doses
a day, we're still going to look pretty good
in four to five weeks.
If we can get to four million doses a day,
it'll be even faster.
Now, if we go back to two million doses a
day or even one point six, one point five
million, we give the variants more opportunity
in time to spread.
We prolong this.
Let's not do that, OK?
Full eligibility for adults right now in every
state.
Very, very simple.
Just get yourself vaccinated, then figure
out whether you can convince somebody else
to
do it.